this is
no longer a city of one and a half
million people many have fled
the russians are raising whole
residential districts to the ground
they say civilians are being used as
human shields and that soldiers are
hiding among them
but how can they tell from up there as
the bombs continue to
indiscriminately
[Music]
the battle for kiev continues too with
daily shelling that includes residential
buildings from russian positions just 15
kilometers away
and closer quarters fighting on its
suburban outskirts
western intelligence assessments point
to a ground offensive that has largely
stalled with russian troops making
little or no
progress but if towns like urpin butcher
and ostomel were to form a path could
open up for a push on the capital
and russia maintains its stranglehold on
mariopol the southern port city another
important strategic objective
a convoy of civilian vehicles reportedly
two thousand of them left via a
humanitarian corridor that held for a
second day
but still no aid supplies made it in
and still hundreds of thousands exist in
conditions of unimaginable hardship
bodies are said to lie uncollected in
the street supplies of food water and
medicine near exhausted
easing the flight of mario paul was a
key demand of the ukrainian side in
ceasefire talks that continued on
tuesday but there is a lot more still to
do
on behalf of the ukrainian people we
give you a chance to live if you
surrender to our forces we will treat
you as humans have to be treated with
dignity the way you have not been
treated by your own army and the way
your army does not treat our people
choose so a second day of cease-fire
talks and separately an advisor to
president zelinski has said he believes
the war will be over by may at the very
latest a prediction based on
intelligence reports of slower than
expected russian progress larger than
expected russian losses its forces
spread increasingly thinly across the
vastness of north south and eastern
ukraine
wishful thinking perhaps
the units of the people's militia of the
donets republic continued to compress
the encirclement in mariopol the general
advance from the east the northern and
western direction was up to 800 meters
the divisions of the russian armed
forces are continuing offence of
operations
there are reports that russia has
already prevailed on allies like china
and syria for help
but all the heart in this fight belongs
to ukraine and it refuses to submit
joe nahul al jazeera will leave